hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the speed
chase Championship quarterfinals it's
Magnus Carlsen vs Fabiano caruana it is
one of the formats where Fabi is
actually higher rated than Magnus
Carlson and uh yeah we've seen it in the
previous video if you didn't
um uh see you can see that uh Nakamura
is already in the semi-finals uh facing
nihal sarin and in the quarterfinals we
have Magnus versus uh caruana and uh
Wesley so we'll be facing Maxima
Sherlock to see who will join them in
the semi-finals now this is the first
game of the match it just finished and I
didn't think I'd um I'll be showing it
so quickly but I do have time before the
Croatia Argentina match
um so uh decided to do it as it is a
very nice one so let's dive straight
into it Magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with Pawn to D4 uh we have
Knight to F6 by Fabi fantasy for E6
Knight to C3 and the bishop to B4 yeah
going for the names of Indian defense we
have Queen to C2 and now uh Fabi Castle
saw the classical variation of the nimzo
A3 Bishop captures and now you don't
have to mess up your Pawn structure you
can capture with the queen Pawn to D5
with C captures on D5 and now Knight the
E4 first this is very rare and um uh
very interesting but Magnus has faced it
once he played it in 2009 against
Vladimir kramnik in the tal Memorial uh
the game ended in a draw and we'll be
following that game for quite some time
up until move 12 so Queen to C2 moving
the queen back e captures on D5 and now
Bishop to F4 with the threat of
capturing and C7 so nicely developing
the bishop witch Tempo Knight the C6 and
now Pawn to E3 defending the D4 Pawn we
have Rook E8 Knight to F3 and now in the
style of of kramnik himself as he also
likes to do this Pawn to G5 attacking
the bishop here with Bishop to G3 and
now in that game did we mentioned from
the Tom Memorial 2009 uh kramnik played
G4 right away but Fabi prepares it with
Pawn to H5 and now there is one game
where Knight the E5 was played but here
Magnus just goes for the developing
Bishop to D3 and it is now as of move 13
that we have a completely new game uh so
Ponte H4 continuing to harass magnus's
Bishop uh Bishop to Eve E5 and now
Bishop to F5 first adding a Defender to
the E4 uh knight uh before deciding
whether or not to capture the bishop on
E5 but it's uh such a beautiful Bishop
of course you will capture it we have
pawned the H3 stopping any further
advancements uh and now Knight captures
on E5 we have D captures on E5 and here
Queen to E7 and queen to E7 is the first
uh basically up until this point
everyone played the first engine move
but here Fabi goes for the third engine
move the first one is C5 which is very
interesting and also it's very
interesting how Magnus replies the queen
to A7 so here we have Queen to E7 and
Magnus immediately goes for Pawn to B4
uh stopping what was basically the
engine's first recommendation and that
is spawn to C5 so okay Fabi prepares it
Rook 8 the C8 and the Magnus castle with
Bishop back to G6 and now Rook ate the
C1 as the first file to open up is
probably going to be the C file it makes
sense the double or even triple up if
possible on the C file Pawn to C6 Fabi
doesn't want to go for the immediate C5
it's always an option so First Pawn to
C6 we have rook fd1 and now Pawn to B6
we have knighted the H2 and now uh
Magnus Has Lifted his ePhone E5 Pawn
defenseless and Fabi should think twice
before capturing it but he goes for it
Queen captures an E5 and the idea is
that now Ponte F3 will dislodge the
Knight and Magnus will capture on G6 but
okay Fabi can always go back he's gonna
be able to trade Queens but Magnus saw
something else as he will be winning the
C6 Pawn so Knight to G3 by far B we have
Bishop captures and G6 F captress and
queen captures with check we have Queen
to G7 and now the move that Magnus
played very nicely Rook captures on C6
and it's a very nice trick because you
cannot capture on C6 otherwise Queen
captures 98 with check will pick up the
other Rook as well so instead after Rook
captures on C6 just Queen captures and
G6 we have Rook captures and G6 King F7
and now Magnus gobbles up another Pawn a
rook captures on G5 and now it's six
pawns Magnus uh Four Points Fabi uh
pawns Fabi but uh Fabi does have the D4
move which um sort of equalizes the game
white is a little bit better but nothing
spectacular Knight to G4 by Magnus and
now saying uh okay you can capture an E3
but if you capture an E3 then I have
some Knights the E5 check ideas maybe
King F6 F4 uh creating a very very
complicated game uh which uh would be
the best course of action for Fabi in
fact but instead Fabi plays Rook to C3
and now Magnus advances his pawn pawn to
E4 uh Rook E5 is also a very nice move
but okay it's a Blitz game Pawn to E4 we
have rooked d8 now getting ready to
advance the past D pawn and Magnus
starts advancing the past E Pawn and
here we have rooked C6 by Fabi guarding
that E6 square but this move also loses
the game completely for Fabi but it's
not easy to spot y so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on sporting uh the
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is of course Pawn
to B5 which would not be possible I'm
sure you you know what uh what I was
about to say but yeah spawn the B5 and
the problem is there is no good square
and once you move the Rook from the
sixth rank E6 check will be devastating
to give you a few examples let's say
Rook to G6 you want to trade Rooks not a
problem just Rook captures King captures
and pawn to E6 You're Gonna Play rookie
8 or something doesn't really matter
King F2 and now after because of the the
Knight and pawn Now cover the F6 and F7
squares the king cannot approach the
pawn so how do you play this you can go
King G7 now Rook to E5 and if let's say
King f8 you want to blockade the pawn
Knight the F6 attacks the real place a
rookie seven Knight D5 and after
something like Rook 8 E7 with check and
that's it uh there's no playing this
with black because uh the the point here
is Immortal you can never reach it the
king cannot enter the game The Rook and
the Knight cover the E6 and F6 squares
so the the king and Rook are absolutely
useless in this game and another thing
if you don't go Rook to G6 if you try
blockading with Rook to G Rook the E6
then F4 with F5 next and that's all
there is let's say D3 F5 you're gonna
move the Rook now look at this Knight H6
check King f8 and now everything is
forced The Rook J check King E7 Rook the
G7 check only moved King to f8 and now
of course Rook to F7 will be Checkmate
so absolutely devastating however Magnus
missed it B5 absolutely crushing he
started with F4 which is still fine but
now Fabi can easily equalize Pawn to D3
Pawn to F5 and Ponte D2 as you can see
this is much much faster for black we
have Pawn to E6 with check King to E7
and now Rook the G7 check King to D6 and
Rook to D1 necessary to stop the
advancement of the pass deep on Rook the
C1 trying the force a rook trade to get
the queen into the game but Magnus has
the only move that saves him and that is
Knight to E3 defending the Rook here and
fabi's best choice is to capture The
Rook if he does this let's say Knight
captures an F5 he is perfectly fine here
let's say Rook D7 check Magnus will have
nothing better either than to trade
everything and then you just pick up
this pawn and you enjoy a game maybe
you're up a pawn but nothing too serious
so instead Fabi played King the E5 and
now he gives Magnus the advantage he
needed Rook to D7 uh trying to force a
rook trade but if you don't then just
The Rook captures uh on D2 and even if
you go for Rook Captain D1 check Knight
captures on D1 it's not much better you
can't trade because the pawn is then
Unstoppable and if you just move the
Rook uh again nothing nothing to it just
Knight to the E3 the D1 square is
covered so you don't really care and
that's it if Rook the C1 with check
you're gonna play King to F2 and you
don't mind any D1 checking ideas because
both the rook and the Knight cover this
Square so black is out of options here
so Rook D the C8 was played uh trying to
keep keep everything in the game but now
Magnus just picks up the the rook and D2
Rook captures on D2 King the E4 attacks
the Knight King the F2 we have Knight
characters on F5 Rook captures and C1 we
have Rook characters on C1 and now
Knight captures on F5 King captors and
of course the pawn is now Unstoppable we
have Pawn to E7 as the E1 square is
covered Fabi goes Rook to C8 and now
Rook to d8 uh Magnus uh uh forces
resignation and he was in this position
unmove 43 that Fabi resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you either trade and then white gets a
queen into the game or you do nothing
move the Rook somewhere you can give a
few checks but doesn't really matter
once uh that is finished next move
Magnus will bring a Queen into the game
uh so yeah very nicely done by Magnus
winning uh the first game we'll see what
happens in the other games but as the
day Croatia is playing Argentina I will
be watching that so it's it's hard to
say when I will show the next game from
the match as if we do well some uh
celebrations will be in order uh so so
we'll see how it goes uh but yeah very
nicely done by Magnus in the first game
Fabi played it well he surprised Magnus
uh but it would seem that Magnus
um I did uh did quite okay and it could
have gone either way but in in no
situation did Fabi get like the upper
hand or anything it was either equal or
Magnus was just a better or straight out
winning and especially in this position
after Rook to C6 where he had the win
with Ponte B5 uh which you guys know
that have found
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it the first game will be
showing from the speechers championship
quarter final match between Magnus and
Fabiano uh should be should be a nice
one uh I would like to thank Logan Dobe
Jeff Graves Francis Sarah Benjamin
Richie and Timothy Rosen for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day